this morning the clark county school
board is going to be taking up an issue
of what a lot of parents say is an
increase in violence on campus new
critics want more security on campuses
and they want the district to take
action hector mejia live this morning
with a look at the problem and look
ahead to this morning's meeting hector
good morning to you
good morning that special board meeting
scheduled for this morning after recent
graphic violent videos brought up the
issue again i just read through emails
between trustees now posted online with
the agenda and in those trustees admit
the concerns are huge and time sensitive
students have been speaking out lately
parents too
claiming there's been a lack of security
when fights break out nevada pta tells
me it seems like things are escalating
rather than being resolved the group's
president rebecca garcia says while it
does take an entire community to solve
the issue the district needs to do their
part by being more transparent
there are certain schools that are
seeing
much more of an increase than others so
how is the district moving resources to
ensure that those schools that may be
having the greatest challenges are
getting the most support
and those are questions that we don't
have the answer to
ccsd has issued statements following the
recent videos shared online
investigations have been launched but
parents want to see more action we are
expecting to hear what the district
plans to do next when it comes to
policies and procedures they do have
time for public comment the meeting is
happening during school hours at 8
o'clock this morning reporting live
hector mejia live local now